[Musique]
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
depuis quelques secondes la guerre fait
à nouveau rage dans le bus registre
septentrionale des milliers de réfugiés
ivre de joie fui la capitale drucker à
l'omc pour des centaines de personnes
auraient été atteintes par des éclats de
rire le chef du pays le chèque marcel
venne mars elle se serait enfuie dans la
montagne avec son conseiller militaire
préféré ambert ben robert mais cela
reste évidemment à vérifier roberval
robert n'est pas un inconnu sur la scène
internationale puisque avant d'être
conseiller militaire il avait été
danseuse nue pendant quelques années au
pigalle aunis maru nightmare pardonnez
moi mon prononciation toujours est il
que ce couple donc le chèque marcel benz
marcel et robert ben robert qui se
tiennent la main pardon qui tiennent en
main les destinées du pays le couple
aurait emporté avant de s'enfuir un
saucisson royal a light iii yaourt
nature et une banane pour deux
d'autre part selon certaines rumeurs
circulant
entre droguée à l'aubour et quimper le
couple aurait également emporté avant de
s'enfuir une collection complète de
confettis royaux datant du xiiie siècle
avant ma soeur qui aura comme chacun le
sait des quintuplés au mois de mars
prochain affaire à suivre donc crofton
en france dépêchez-vous un thé vous de
faire le plein car demain mauvaise
nouvelle le pain va passer à 6 francs le
litre
inauguration ce matin d'un centre de
recherche pour les inaugurations
officielles amenant sur mantes ce centre
hyper sophistiqué servira comme son nom
l'indiqué a inauguré au maximum lors des
inaugurations un reportage de réellement
lagny thorigny pantone
dans quelques instants sur vos écrans le
reportage vraiment la nuit torride bande
à part je me suis un incident technique
oui oui oui et bien bien alors nous ne
verrez pas le reportage de raymond lagny
thorigny pomponne excusez moi mais on
vient de m'apprendre qu'il vient d'être
viré
non je m'excuse encore oui mon très bien
très bien d'accord il vient d'être viré
pour des raisons qui ne sont absolument
pas politique me demandant de préciser
avec insistance en août
domaine social on ne signale aucun
mouvement particulier de grève ou
d'arrêts de travail aucun conflit majeur
qui vaille la peine d'être souligné
notons cependant que c'était aujourd'hui
la première journée du congrès national
du cnp j le cnp qui je le rappelle est
le conseil national du patronat joyeux
mais c'est au nombre de 2500 qu'ils se
sont retrouvés les adhérents du cnpg
hilare à leurs assises fluide glacial
camembert à musique couteau gondolant et
sucre moussan dans leur tasse à café ont
permis d'analyser dans la bonne humeur
les différents problèmes auxquels
doivent faire face les patrons joyeux
dans un tout autre domaine un objet
volant non identifié aurait été aperçu
aux environs de limoges très exactement
à prouilhe aller mourgues dans le
calvados
metz après enquête le témoin un cafetier
aurait déclaré je cite j'étais
complètement bourré
l'audiovisuel c'est pas n'importe quoi
c'est ce qu'a déclaré en substance
pierre la rue michaud attachée spécial
du président qui n'a pas voulu en dire
plus mais on sait cependant que pierre
lescure le courageux directeur d'antenne
2 autorise désormais tous les
présentateurs a présenté le journal
télévisé avec le moins d'effets
possibles et cela afin de laisser le
plus d'impact aux nouvelles dont ils
sont porteurs tous les présentateurs ont
accepté de se plier à cette directive
seul triste fait donc rend triste et non
prescrits seule christine au grand
pardon a refusé de se montrer torse nu
complètement
elle négocie actuellement dans le bureau
de pierre lescure car elle tient à
garder sans son corsage son collier sa
montre et son indépendance face aux
pressions des mouvements féministes qui
ne voient pas d'un bon oeil cette
nouvelle poussée machiste sport à
présent rubrique sportive les vaincus
ont essuyé un cuisant échec un peu
partout en france tandis que les
vainqueurs sortent la tête haute et
bannières au vent les stades de france
la météo maintenant je m'excuse elle se
compose aujourd'hui de vent frais
de deux glaçons pour la mériter les
températures relevées sous abri à 16h03
à limoges 6 à marseill deux à sept
essais à 2 a clairement fait
je vous laisse à présent passer une très
bonne soirée en compagnie de champs
elysées et de michel drucker en
compagnie de daniel prévost et daniel
prévost et ce pour être où je m'excuse
je vous retrouve demain sauf bien sûr si
j'ai 37 5 sous le bras
je ne voulais pas à demain bonsoir mais
le coeur y est à demain bonsoir
[Musique]